du jour appelle la question orale numéro
58 de Monsieur Michel well toujours à
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture de
l'alimentaire et de la forêt
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues depuis
plusieurs années nombre de départements
français et notamment la Seine-et-Marne
sont confrontés à la prolifération des
chenilles processionnaires les élus des
communes touchées par ce phénomène on va
faire face à une véritable invasion de
chenille qui engendre des risques
sanitaires graves aussi bien pour les
animaux domestiques que pour les
populations
les méthodes de lutte contre ce fléau
sont connus l'idéal étant bien sûr les
actions préventives qui peuvent qui
peuvent être menées au plan
départemental certes la gestion de la
prolifération des chenilles
processionnaires du chêne relève de la
compétence du maire et du préfet eu
égard leur pouvoir de police néanmoins
les coûts de traitement sont très élevés
et difficiles à assumer pour les
communes rurales même si elles peuvent
en facturer une partie aux propriétaires
privés il ne reste pas moins vrai que le
traitement sur le domaine public demeure
important et plus particulièrement
lorsque la commune possède des terrains
boisés la coordination des actions de
lutte apparaît également indispensable
pour être efficace les mesures isolées
de quelques communes s'étant soldées par
des dépenses inutiles et sans résultat
sur le long terme
je vous montre donc monsieur le ministre
ce que vous comptez faire pour soutenir
les départements touchés et enfin
parvenir à une véritable éradication
d'un phénomène aux conséquences parfois
très grave sur la santé des populations
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
le Président Monsieur sénateur m'avait
donc alerté ce matin sur une question
très précise et spécifique sur le
problème de la prolifération des
chenilles processionnaires
je sais que des campagnes de prévention
ont été engagées par plusieurs agences
régionales de la santé
je sais aussi que
dans de nombreuses endroits en
particulier Aquitaine Pays de Loire
Île-de-France des actions de Luke par
épandage aériens ont été lancés je
précise d'ailleurs que les produits qui
sont utilisés sont des produits de
l'agriculture biologique mais il y a un
phénomène constaté maintenant qui est la
prolifération et où la recrudence et le
développement de ce problème des
chenilles processionnaires en
particulier en Île-de-France
c'est pourquoi il y a une étude qui a
été engagée en particulier de
surveillance sanitaire dans deux zones
connues pour abriter des populations de
chenilles
une dans votre département et l'autre
dans le Val-d'Oise
je suis obligé de ce matin pour répondre
à la question qui m'est posée de vous
dire que nous allons tirer toutes les
conclusions des études qui ont été
faites et qui semble indiquer que en
partie le réchauffement climatique soit
aussi un facteur qui
encourage si je puis dire au
développement de ces chenilles et il
faudra à partir de là en tirer des
conclusions à la fois au niveau des
épandages qui peuvent être demandés et
puis comme vous l'avez dit aussi au
niveau financier je sais que ça coûte
cher pour des communes qui sont
concernées et il faudra que au niveau à
la fois des communes des régions des
départements et de l'état nous puissions
ensemble mettre autour de la table les
éléments nécessaires pour résoudre ce
problème
le ministre monsieur well
bien je remercie monsieur le ministre de
sa réponse et il était bien évident
qu'en tant que président l'Union des
Maires du département de Seine-et-Marne
je suis parti prenant pour participer
aux différentes études que vous pouvez
mener monsieur le ministre merci